hallo mein name ist mein name ist
unendlich willkommen hier zu einem neuen
video ihr habt mir bei twitter videos
eingesendet unter dem hashtag locker
reagiert und ich das ganze ist jetzt
einfach irgendwie neues format also ihr
könnt mir videos senden unter dem
hashtag locker reagiert das ist das
ganze format oder nehme ich in jeder
folge ein paar komische clips ein paar
fragen die ich noch am ende beantworte
und hab gerade so über gott und die welt
nachgedacht und dabei kam mir dann in
den sinn wie scheiße eine videos
eigentlich so alles klar wir haben
direkt eine beleidigung sofort anfangen
aber so mag ich das nur deshalb habe ich
mir gedacht dass ich dich einfach mal
schnell mal danke alter ich finds echt
ultras wenn leute die einfach ein talent
haben was malerische künstlerische
musikalische sachen angeben die das
einfach ausleben das dem youtuber dann
widmet und dann die sache war da fehlt
halt irgendwie noch das gewisse etwas
das habe ich einfach noch das
hinzugefügt ich denke das entspricht so
ziemlich deinem niveau ja mach auf
keinen fall weiter mit deinen scheiß
videos ja das war ich glaube ich dir du
hast mich spezialist oder englisch meint
luca das alpaka 36 wollte selber mal so
ein kleines baby alpaka kauf unternehmen
die sammlung setzen mit kuli die balu
und so den man auch einen namen geben
ich weiß gar nicht deinen namen ich habe
es außerdem nach dir bin als junger was
gegen samir benannt
das ultra lied falls es zum kopf
keiner hat mich von den amis alter das
ist heute alles voll mit irgendwelchen
stofftieren die von ihren besitzern arm
genommen werden und dann so gewunken
wird und alles um das was bist du für
ein mensch alt habe mir wurde auch vor
allem wochen animationen zugesellt
animation
also das ist sie sind ein paar bilder
anhand ag sieht aber schon ordentlich
cool aus ich würde mir von mimi die bist
du mir das einfach in einem video
genommen die ton datei quasi ich auch
was reagiert habe ich doch das war bei
der c hkd cnc erkannte man dieses
komische spielen wo man zusammen
erschaffen hat kommt man auf jeden fall
aus irgendwelchen sachen such skulptur
erschaffen vielleicht wendet noch wissen
wie das heißt könnte jetzt einmal in die
kommentare schreiben
den link dazu passten oder so und ich
glaube dass die tonspur woche doch
informationen einfach bild rako geworden
sie da die wartehallen
es ist noch hell draußen ist es bei dir
auch so
ja bei mir auch hell ist hat zum tag an
sich ich hab die schon im kindergarten
gemalt bist du nicht wunderschön
geworden alter ich glaube die serie muss
nicht lokal sondern ein verlegen wie ihr
beleidigt luca oder irgendwie so weil
irgendwie alles was ich sehe sie yorker
cops genommen wie du dummkopf ich hab
dich schon im kindergarten gemacht wird
sondern übels hässliches ding gezeigt
sowie falls du das wirklich schön fahren
das dann möchte ich nicht deine gefühle
verletzen das ist wirklich sehr schön
geworden
ich kann mir das nicht mehr geben man
wirklich war das video dauert gut okay
dann schaue ich jetzt nach weiteren aber
wählen der typ macht weiter mit dieser
komischen
sind alle meine fans so bekloppt das ist
mein haustier
ich mag einen tomatensaft salat läuft es
besser tomaten okay wenn man so eine
aussage trifft dann kann ich dir
tatsächlich noch eine sache hier gerade
empfehlen uns mal dass für das ist die
tür
da kommst du gern rausgehen ich weiß
auch nicht wenn ich das nachher
schneidet denke ich mir wieder zu luca
weise danke schadet mein t-shirt an
wieder scheiße tanzen als dumm rumstehen
an alle leute die so cool denken dass
ihm cool sind wenn es langweilig ein
wäscheständer den preis für die
kreativste einbindung bekommt auf jeden
fall du und wäscheständer habe ich auf
jeden fall noch nie gesehen mein
wäscheständer ist dieses klapprige dinge
das alter was denken sich leute wenn sie
mir einfach einen selber machen unter
dem hashtag von wiljo abonnierten
instagram bekannt wahrscheinlich bis zu
16 jahre alt und das entweder sondern
möchte gern playboy bild von einem nicht
vorhandenen sixpack als instagram
profilbild oder irgendwas total schulen
aus bitter irgendwie steht
ich meine ich möchte ich nicht angehen
aber denkst du bist in irgendeiner form
damit erfolgreich wenn du deine
gesperrtes profil irgendwie unter dem
hashtag verbreitest da sammelst du nur
hey man wirklich eine ernste message
leute die sowas machen werden von mir
instant geblockt denn da leute schreiben
dieses video als optimal war warum tut
ihr das produziert guten content dann
erhaltet ihr eure zuhörerschaft oder
zuschauerschaft aber nicht über solche
menschen hasse allein dieses komplette
in sachen gehörig post mein bizeps ich
poste deine muskeln ich mach hier
geboren hier ist weg ich hab ein kleid
und ich bin fechenheim schreibt eine
abkürzung inventar ist es mit vielen
leuten als sorry for hetzen aber
irgendwie ja irgendwie hässlich weil oft
na ich bin in der ratsarbeit 20 minuten
ich weiß nicht wie lange das video nach
er wird deswegen würde ich sagen haben
wir jetzt eben schnell fünf kurze fragen
raus sie hier hat die frage nicht in dem
video gestellt allerdings in ihrem
twitter post an mich und 20 gefragt ob
umarmungen übermorgen erlaubt sind und
ob sie mich umarmen
weil übermorgen mache ich ein fan
treffen in wien übrigens gibt es da noch
tickets eigentlich durfte jeder youtuber
der das 150 tickets verlosen verkaufen
wird erwartet ob die kosten 10 euro aber
man bekommt dafür auch irgendwie was zu
essen und ein beutel und inhalte also da
die 150 bei mir direkt weg wahrhaben
dass bei mir auf 400 hoch gesteckt das
halt wenn ihr theoretisch in österreich
wohnen oder umgebung oder euch sagt sido
ich bin ein wenig brauch unbedingt noch
ein ticket ich hab euch den linken die
beschreibung passt dass es bit.ly /
congress for community da könnte das
kaufen aber seit schnell weil ich weiß
nicht über ticket ist noch gibt es also
nur ihr habt hier mit noch mal die
möglichkeit weil er
die geht so schnell weg waren dass noch
mehr leute kommen können nun zu deiner
frage umarmungen ist bei mir eigentlich
immer so eine sache weil ich mich total
schnell anstecken und ich dafür nicht
anstecken meister nach korso phase habe
deswegen denke ich dass uns trotzdem
klar gehen aber nicht mit diesem konto
höhere posten du kannst du ein update
geben über einen lukasz ob also was
demnächst reinkommen ich kann dir ein
update geben
die jetzigen produkte die drin sind also
die smiley shirts mit dem smile ich hier
an der brusttasche werden auslaufen das
heißt es sind die letzten produkte
gerade im shop das als wenn ihr davon
noch als wollt müsst ihr das auf jeden
fall den nächsten tagen bestellen was
dem nächsten rein kommen wird ist ein
ich hole mal ganz schnell das t shirt
ein paar sekunden später dieses t shirt
hier wird in den luca shop.com ich
feiere das übel weil ein smiley ist
einfach in weiß und die ganzen anderen
seht ihr vielleicht sind in schwarz und
das ganze stadt ist man in so einem
coolen dünneren stoff für sommer jetzt
hat meine nachbarin finster hackett auf
das shirt wird die nächsten tage kommen
das werde ich noch mal in einem twitter
paus erwähnen also wir am besten von
instagram
sollte mal zeigen was sich zum beispiel
so finster im hochlager ihr tue ich
beispielsweise so als würde ich in new
york vom hochhaus runterspringen hier
benutze ich ein laserschwert penis folgt
mir ich halte dort laserdrucker oder das
sein und was demnächst auch kommen wird
aber ich denke das dauert noch ein paar
wochen oder so zwei drei wochen
erschossen
ich hatte euch einmal gefragt ob ihr
euch bettwäsche kissen oder so was in
die richtung vorstellen könnte auf jeder
bock drauf habe da meinen alle so jung
macht doch einfach nicht die leute
kaufen oder nicht ist er deren
entscheiden und bisher durch bestimmt
nicht geld geld das sind die kissen das
ist die rückseite das ist die
vorderseite alter die werden richtig
geil das könnt ihr alles über luca
schöpfung de dann kaufen soll aber
keinen kleinen video hierfür nur für den
shops 1 alles klar auf jeden fall danke
für deine korrekte einsendung zur frage
luca ist irgendwelche neuen projekte
also so richtig große projekt die sache
ist dass es steht er in minecraft nero
bevor da sage ich aber morgen wie soll
ich dann nicht dabei wenn riesige
projekte die ich selber nichts ich mache
eigentlich youtube jeden tag denke ich
nirgendwo wird neues aus dass es so das
konzept von einem kanal also ich will
mich jetzt nicht langfristig an ein
projekt bin
es gibt bei youtube neuerdings eine
möglichkeit dass man wenn man das ganz
genau in die linse wird das bleibt dann
direkt bei dir an der brust das war mein
gott dann kräftig funktioniert warum
kriegen wir so beschied wirklich cool
windmann er hat eine chance die tricks
kugel an dieser stelle würde ich das
video werden
folien schmerz mich immer klappt am ende
von dem video wenn euch das video
gefallen hat und ihr euch denkt ja ich
hab auch ne frage und ein video und
mitteln nicht ziemlich klar heraus zieht
es einfach unter hashtag locker reagiert
auf twitter als videoformat dann kommt
er vielleicht in die nächste folge
natürlich sagen dass es von einem video
ich freue mich über eine bewertung
schaffen gibt 470.000 was ist
realistisch ich dachte das ja nie so oft
mit an zahlen aber naja ihr findet links
zu dem fenster für morgen in der
beschreibung wir sehen uns ich hoffe
dass ich kann man nicht vom staat
zufällt ganz so oft auf meinen tisch lag
und meine nachbarn denken